I don't read comic books I don't go see
the comic book movies except when the
daily wire forces me too I'm not a big
fan however I have to defend the comic
books a little bit
because there's a new hubbub over DC
Comics in which apparently it's a Batman
comic I used to really like Batman when
I was a kid and in the Batman comic the
Joker
who is a man
becomes pregnant and gives birth to a
mud monster
who transforms into a child version of
the Joker and who he then adopts as his
son
apparently the some other villain
in the comic book pushes The Joker into
a big pile of mud
and the curse that this character puts
on Joker doesn't work and the Joker
becomes pregnant
and now some people are reacting and
saying this is DC Comics going woke this
is pushing the transgender agenda in our
comics and this is terrible and I I
actually have no problem with this
he's the Joker
He's the bad guy
it's it's okay I I think in artistic
depictions and certainly in mythological
depictions which is what the superhero
stories are I think it's okay
when
disordered
experiences and desires and states of
being are represented in the bad guys I
would I would not be so Placid about it
all if Batman became pregnant that would
be pretty weird that would probably be
pushing A woke thing but yeah the Joker
is a pretty disordered guy and it's
pretty disordered for a guy to get
pregnant
I I have no problem when Milton and
Paradise Lost represents Satan as giving
birth through his head to sin and death
it's kind of trans I guess but not not
really it's okay it's a it's a
mythological depiction of something and
something that's that's quite evil and
quite disordered so I
if the comic books want to portray
transgenderism as just bizarre and wrong
and evil and something The Joker does
okay that's fine
something you should avoid now if the
Joker becomes the hero then then I guess
we have a problem Democrat
representative Robert Garcia
whenever we get a Speaker of the House
plans to take the oath of office not on
a Bible
but on a comic book
representative elect Garcia has said
that he is he's issuing the Bible
he's going to swear his oath of office
on the Constitution
on his citizenship papers on a picture
of his dead parents and on a Superman
comic that he borrowed from the
government
very childish obviously to take the oath
of office on a comic it's embarrassing
it's humiliating for our whole country
and certainly for this guy
there's something deeper going on though
the the shallow take on this is just wow
this is an overgrown Man Child what a
joke or congress we're living in clown
world but there's something deeper going
on because the purpose of swearing the
oath of office is that you are swearing
by that which you worship that which you
hold most sacred that to which you feel
most accountable
the whole purpose of the oath of office
it's not just some empty ritual that we
do because people used to do it in the
old timey days we do it because what you
were saying is I promise that I will
work for the common good I'll defend the
Constitution I'll I won't be corrupt
I'll pursue good and avoid evil and I'm
swearing by my God man God help me if I
do not do that okay and so if you if you
believe in God if you believe that such
a vow matters
you're more likely to keep your promises
but for the modern lib types who don't
believe in God it's not just that then
there is a void it's that you swear by
other gods so the gods that he is
swearing by here are the gods of the
state his citizenship papers even the
Constitution the fact that he would
swear by that means that
what he holds most dear what he holds
most sacred is the state
his ancestors
and a myth I won't even just call it a
child story which Superman is but but a
myth
so that is
valuable there is Great Value in the
state there's Great Value in your
ancestors there's Great Value in myths
but it's a sorry
comparison to God
and and it's Pagan too is the other
thing in Pagan societies
in Godless societies
people swear by the state the state is
held as the Supreme thing or one's
ancestors people when they give up God
they engage in a kind of ancestor
worship or myths you think of the old
Greek and Roman myths which are
different from True Religion which
worships the one true God in a way which
is logical that's why we have theology
the the Pagan myths do not have theology
the the Pagan myths do not are not
identified with the logos you actually
see this going back all the way to the
ancient Greek writers distinguishing
between the kind of story The
mythological stories of the Gods and
the true God the truth the logic the the
the first Mover The Creator
this is a natural consequence of a
society that is giving up God and
specifically giving up Christianity
which has animated our civilization and
has allowed our civilization to become
the greatest in the history of the world
and as we give that up expect a lot more
confused people taking their oath of
office on a comic book
and and I tell you I don't want to put
the good of my Society my future my
family my state my country I'm willing
to stake that on God I am not I am not
willing to stake that on a comic book
okay I trust that God will see us
through that's where I put my trust we
write that on our money here in God we
trust that's our motto it's in the
national anthem
in Superman I do not trust
the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member right now it is fake headline
Friday I need your help to to guide me
along as Virgil guided Dante as I try to
discern which of the five headlines my
producer Ben Davies has given me is the
fake headlines so head on over daily
wire.com use code Knowles at checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
daily wire.com Knowles
[Music]
foreign
[Music]